هذا فيديو
لمقرئ شهير يرقص ويغني على انغام اغنيه
لام كلثوم في حفل شعبيه اثار غضبا واسعا
في مصر طبعا
التواصل تداولوا فيديو المقرئ الشهير
ممدوح عامر وهو يتبادل فيه الرقص والاغاني
ما اثار غضبا واسعا وايضا انتقادات بعدم
احترام المقرئ لمكانته الدينيه القارئ كشف
انه بالفعل قام بالرقص والغناء في حفل
زفاف شقيقه مؤكدا انه تعامل كما يتعامل
الجميع في مثل هذه المناسبات فيما اعلنت
نقابه محفظيه او حافظي وقراءه القران
الكريم استنكارها للفيديو المتضمن رقص
المقرئ وتمايله وغنائه مثل مطربي
المهرجانات كما كشف مسؤول هذه النقابه ان
النقابه نقابه القراء تقوم حاليا بفحص
الفيديو لمعرفه ملابسات لاتخاذ قرار بشان
المقرئ
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
انا اليوم مصمم ما عندي لا شغل ولا مشغله
بشوف الشيخ ممدوح عامر صباح الخير يا شيخ
ممدوح
صباح الخير على حضرتك وعلى مشاهدينك
الكرام الله يخليك خليني افهم ايه اللي
حصل يعني
اشعلت السوشيال ميديا بهذا الفيديو وهذا
الغناء
بالتاكيد ما فيش حد يعني في وضعي او الناس
بتنظر له النظره بتاعتي كان يحب ان هو
يظهر بهذا الشكل
لمتابعينه او لجمهور او لاي حد بيسمع او
بيحب يسمع القران الكريم ولكن انا يعني
يعني تصرفت التصرف ده بشكل تلقائي وشكل
عفوي جدا
يعني ده على اعتبار ان انا كنت صاحب فرح
ده فرح اخويا
ويعني
القصه يعني جت بدون ترتيب او بدون اي
شيء مني يعني يعني
قدر الله وما شاء فعل والحمد لله هو يا
شيخ طبعا دائما شيخ ممدوح عن مشاعر
الانسانيه الصادقه هذه تخرج وتفيض منها من
دون اي حساب يعني وبدون ما نستطيع ان
نتبعها على كل حال شيخ ممدوح يعني من بعض
الانتقادات التي وجهت لك بانه يعني هذا
التصرف لا يليق بمقرئ وشيخ دين مثل حضرتك
ماذا تقول في ذلك يعني كيف تفسر هي صح
مشاعر تلقائيه طبيعيه ولكن الم تفكر في
هذا الامر قبل الفرح او على الاقل عندما
نظرت ورايت بان هناك الكثير من الكاميرات
ممكن ان تاخذ فيديوهات وصور لك
لا لا لانه هو الفرح كان فرح اسري يعني
كان يعني في حدود الاقرباء والجيران ما
كانش الدنيا موسعه يعني دي نمره واحد نمره
اتنين
انا معرفش انه الموضوع ممكن يوصل الى هذا
الحد لانه انا ما كنتش يعني اعرف ان في
كاميرات يعني او حد بيصور او حاجه زي كده
انا تصرفت كانه يعني ده فرحي فرح اخويا
اللي انا مربيه زي في مقام يعني انا في
مقام والده طيب انه والدي متوفي من سنه
ونص وانا باعتبار انا حدد تلقائي يعني من
الناس اللي هي يعني بتهزر وبتضحك ووارد ان
هو
كده يعني واحنا كان عندنا يعني الشيخ سيد
مكاوي كان انا ما بضعش مبررات يعني ولكن
كان هناك من قراء القران الكريم انه اللي
هم ضروري ان هم بيتعلموا الموسيقى عشان
يضبطوا النغم بتاع القران ومن القراء اللي
كان بيضرب عود فعلا ومن كان عندنا الشيخ
محمد عمران وعندنا ما هي القراءات ايضا
مقامات
شيخ بس عاوز اسالك قبل قبل ما اسالك هي
كلمه واحده انت ندمان دلوقتي
ما هو فرح اخوك الناس بتقول انه انت الشيء
اللي بيقرا القران القران مش انسان مش من
حقه يفرح طيب
ولكن يعني انه هو حضرتك لو حضرتك شخصيه
مذيع او شخصيه عامه
وتشوف مثلا حضرتك الناس تراك في فيديو
معين وحضرتك بتهزر او بتعمل موقف معين
الموقف ده انت بتشوف ان هو حق لك بس من من
خصوصياتك يعني ده شيء من الخصوصيات اللي
هو بتعمله مع اولادك مع حبايبك ولكن مش
حابب ان كل الناس تشوف حاجه زي كده انا
الفرح نفسه اه الفرح نفسه ده شيء طبيعي
جدا وانا يعني ده حق اخويا او ابني حقه
عليا ان انا ضروري ان انا افرحه وكذا زائد
ان انا من الناس اللي هي تلقائيه في
مشاعرها اللي زي حالاتنا او اللي في
ظروفنا اللي هو مش مبسوط ليه عشان الفيديو
اتطلع للنجوى
مش مبسوط ليه مش مبسوط ما انت بتفرح لفرح
اخوك يعني
فرحان اه ولكن يعني
المشهد نفسه ان انا يعني
ربما هي مناسبه خاصه
بانه الافضل كان ان تبقى في اطار العالم
انا والله يا شيخ لما تقول مذيع انا واحد
من الناس بضحك وبهزر مع كل الناس اللي
يعرفني واللي ما يعرفنيش وبكون على
طبيعتي
انا اكثر
كمذيع هو قال كمذيع هذا طبعا
انا اكثر من حضرتك جدا طيب
اتفضل اتفضل اكمل فكرتك الشيخ اتفضل
انا انا انا انا كشخص حتى كمقرئ للقران كل
القريبين مني يعرفوا ان انا يعني بهزر
وبضحك مع الجميع ودائما انا يعني دايما
اقول لتلامذتي ما تستحي ان تفعله في يعني
في العالم لا تفعله اصلا يعني ما تريد ان
تفعله في الخفاء فلا تفعله يعني لا تجعل
عملك او شخصيتك او او ما تقدمه للناس يؤثر
على شخصيتك او كذا دع الناس ان تراك
طبيعيا والله يا شيخ ممدوح الفرح
والسعاده ايضا هي من من جوهر الدين انه
الناس تكون سعيده وبالتالي ان شاء الله
يديم الافراح دائما ويبعد عنا الحزن شيخ
ممدوح عامر المقرئ شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا
لمتابعتي المزيد
تصل انسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات